you do so many things you forget you
forget about that yeah and I know that
you did something on our show today one
of our producers came up and said
remember the time Steve Buscemi was on
our show and he did this wrestling move
on Andy and I said nope
and he said that was really funny and
everybody at the time loved it and it
was a fun moment and I went nope don't
have no memory of that I well I got of
course I remember it well and I also
remembered that I felt like you weren't
really into it like you know you kind of
did it but grudgingly and then I felt
bad about it you've described most of my
waking hours I felt bad about this for
years
uh-huh and then I finally then I got to
work with you on Portlandia yeah and I'm
good now I can finally like apologize
and say I'm sorry I sprung that on you
yeah and you looked at me anyone I have
no idea what I have no I saw our
internet people put it online today I
saw just a no recollection I want to
take a look at this clip right now
because I had no recollection and even
when they showed it to me today I'm like
I guess it happened but I have no memory
but here we are it's 1998 and you
proposed doing a wrestling move on Andy
let's take a look m'kay
all right Andy you have to get behind me
this is the ready position and you got
it grab your gun like this okay but I
need this leg
[Applause]
what kind of wrestling move is that when
you have to ask for their leg first cut
their head in this luck and then pardon
me could I have looking at it that you
didn't mind you wouldn't let me lock my
hands that's just well no I wouldn't
well yeah but I mean I didn't have to
assert my dominance yes make it serious
if we wrestled I'd kill you I know I
know and I'm happy for any human contact
so I mean just to be touched yeah he
always saw us please just to beat a ass
now would that know it was bad yes and
then if I do bad improv I didn't like
but you know the other thing is we have
a lot of I've met people that were that
have said to me
yeah Conan I know I was on your show and
I said that thing and you were really
mad and I don't know what they're
talking about and then I'll look at the
tape and go like no I wasn't mad people
get in their heads about stuff
yeah I was mad at you about the wrestler
thing but he was fine with it I don't
like other people touching in I'm mad
now that I was wearing that shirt and
we're going bowling later it's not a big
thing